so somebody that's been criticized for
MLM type schemes is Andrew Tate yeah uh
somebody that I'm
I'm very likely to talk with so for
people who have been
telling me that I'm too afraid to talk
to Andrew Tate first let me just say I'm
not a
fraid to talk to anyone it's just that
certain people require preparation and
you have to like allocate
your life in such a way that you want to
prepare properly for them sure and so
you have to kind of think uh who you
want to prepare for because I have other
folks that have more power than this
particular figure that I'm preparing for
so you have to make sure you uh allocate
your time wisely but I do think he's a
very influential person
uh that raises questions of what it
means to be a man in the 21st century
um and that's a very important and
interesting question because young
people look up to philosophers to
influencers about what it means to be a
man they look up to Jordan Peterson they
look up to Andrew Tate they looked up to
others to other figures I think it's
important to
talk about that to think what does it
mean to be a good man in the Society of
course in the other gender there's the
same question what does it mean to be a
good woman I think obviously the bigger
question is what does it mean to be a
good person but
I swear to God
um
uh the now okay
uh so and that said one aspect of the
criticism that Andrew has received yeah
is not just on the misogyny
is on the MLM aspect of uh the
multi-level marketing schemes they did
so is is there some truth to that is
there some fraudulent aspect to that so
yeah I I definitely think so I mean
that's the main reason I criticized him
um
so let's back up there's a few
clarifications I need to make what
Andrew Tate is selling is not
multi-level marketing although he is
selling the dream he's selling an
affiliate marketing thing which is
slightly different so in multi-level
marketing if I sell to you and then you
go sell to two other people I make money
from those two other people down the
chain multi-level affiliate marketing is
sort of like one level I only make money
so Andrew Tate had this affiliate
program where if you sold Hustler's
University to somebody else which sounds
like something people would Boomers
would put on Facebook in like 2010 like
I went to Hustler's University
um School of Heart by the way you or a
member of Hustler's universities yeah I
joined I joined I became a hustler
that's that's in large part due to my
why I'm so successful is because of my
Hustler University membership I'm just
kidding um but so it's an affiliate
program so you'd sell like I sell to you
this 50 course and I make like five
dollars and Andrew Tate in perpetuity
makes 50 a month off of you okay
what does this course actually sell
right because ultimately he's selling
the dream he's selling hey The Matrix
has enslaved you he's really gone down
this like Neo Rabbit Hole
um so the Matrix has enslaved you your
life is controlled by these people who
want to keep you like kind of weak you
know lazy whatever you need a breakout
and you need to achieve
the the new dream which is sort of like
hustling your way to the top you don't
need the Antiquated systems of of school
you can just pay me 50 a month and I
will teach you everything okay so what
do you actually get well and why is it a
scam so you actually I think it's just a
scam in terms of like value in like
you're selling based on these completely
unrealistic things he's like let's get
rich okay
you get a series of Discord rooms so you
do you know what Discord most people
know what Discord is it's like a bunch
of you know chat rooms basically right
so it's like AOL or is it like yeah yeah
right right well I'm talking to the guy
who who uh quit emacs so I don't know
there's Discord servers and in these
like there's like there's like seven uh
different rooms you can go in or there's
several rooms and each one is like a
different field of making money yes
e-commerce trading cryptocurrency
um I think
fulfillment by Amazon
like copywriting
okay so I went to all of these I checked
them out I checked all their money
making tools the first funny thing is
that Andrew Tate is nowhere to be found
the supposed successful guy that you
like bought into is nowhere to be found
it's these professors that you have now
he has hired and said these guys are
super qualified
so like looked up some of what that some
of these guys have done and some of them
have launched like scammy crypto coins
the cryptocurrency professor was like
Shilling a bunch of coins that did bad
and then like deleted the tweets I mean
just completely he exactly what you'd
expect behind the paywall is nothing of
substance you're not going to learn to
get rich by Escaping The Matrix and
going to work for Jeff Bezos fulfillment
by Amazon is not Escaping The Matrix
right like that's not the way to hustle
to the top it's literally a field of
making money that everyone in the world
has access to if you want to
differentiate yourself and make money
the first thing you realize is going
into skill sets that literally anyone
with an internet account can do is a bad
way to do that because you have to have
some differentiating factor to add value
so
it's just such a
obvious and complete scam because there
is no value to this like so-called
education the professors are crap
the advice they're like hiding some of
the bad things they've done and agitates
nowhere to be found ultimately that's
why everyone joins what he's done is
very interesting because
and I'll give him Credit in his
marketing he's been very Savvy to like
make the reasons you admire him not the
thing he's sort of selling which is
weird like he's selling get rich quick
which seems like it relates to his
persona but is actually very orthogonal
to it his Persona is like the tell it
how it is
like tall buff rich guy it's like
actually his Persona that you're buying
into and then he's selling you this
thing to the side which when people get
in there and they're not delivered on
the product he still is those things
that you first thought he was so it's
like I think it's to some extent he's
made a lot of
money by making the thing that he makes
money on not the thing he gets so much
pushback online for and what he's also
loved for so people will push back for
his misogyny but the real way he's
making money is just like basic get rich
quick schemes that are super obvious to
spot but everyone's distracted by like
oh he said some crazy stuff about women
or you know all these various other
scandals he's gotten himself in to get
more and more and more attention so with
the persona
uh is the Hustler University still
operating I think they've rebranded it
I'm part of their pitch now I'm like
they put me on as like I mean as like
the Matrix is trying to take us out Lex
and then it's me saying like you know
they put me in like saying I'm part of
the Matrix they put me in saying oh this
guy sucks you know I joined it sucks and
so they'll play that and they do like a
bass drop and it's like you know
don't listen to people like this I mean
it's I'm basically like uh you've been
Cooperative by The Matrix to attack yes
you're an Insider threat that
infiltrated right now is being used by
The Matrix to attack him well uh to
everyone who criticizes him as part of
the Matrix he won't say who the Matrix
is it's just it's just the shadowy cabal
of Rich powerful people it's just like
the easy narrative for people who are
disaffected and who feel cheated by the
system you just collectivize that system
and you make it the bad guy and you go
look look those guys those guys have
been cheating you they're the bad guys
they want me
shut up and then now the person that the
the people who harmed you they want this
guy shut up you're going to listen to
him so that's like it's like the most
basic psychological manipulation that
everyone seems to constantly fall for
it's it's really uh trivial and stupid
but can you still man
the case for Hustler's University where
it's actually uh giving young people
confidence
uh teaching and valuable lessons about
like actually incentivizing them to do
something like fulfillment by Amazon the
basic thing to try it sure to learn
about it to fail or maybe see like to
try to give a a catalyst and uh
incentive to try these as much as it
pains me I will try to give a uh a
succinct
maybe Steel Man of it as best as I can
thinking that it's such a grift but um I
think what you would say is that
some people in order to make a change in
their life need a
someone who they can look up to
and men don't have a lot of like strong
role models
like big male presences in their life
who can serve as a proper example so the
most charitable interpretation would be
Andrew Tate
would encourage you to go Reach for the
Stars I guess my problem is I have a
deep like I have a deep issue with the
like lust and greed that centers all
these things it's like this
glorification of
wealth equals status wealth equals good
person wealth and Bugatti equals you are
meaningful you matter and like the dark
underlying thing
is that none of that none of that
matters like none it matters that you
make a decent living but past just like
that I think the like lust for more
stuff and the idolization of these
people that is just like opulence is a
net bad so that's like my steel man has
to stop there because I really disagree
with like the values that are pushed by
people like that yeah no I agree that
that's the thing that should be
criticized I shouldn't say it doesn't
matter I think it's uh just like a an
amazing meal at a great restaurant that
matters it's money and Bugattis for many
people make life beautiful like this
those are all components but I think
money isn't the you can also enjoy a
beautiful life on a hike in nature you
can
um there's a lot of ways to enjoy life
and one of the deepest has been tested
through time is the intimacy close
connection friendship with other people
or with a loved one like they don't talk
about like love yeah what it means to be
deeply connected with another person is
just like get women get money all those
kinds of things but that yeah that I
think I don't want to dismiss that
because there's like value in that
there's fun in that I think the the
positive I don't I haven't investigated
Hustler's University but the positive I
see in general is young people
don't get much respect from society
uh that's easy to call it the Matrix and
so on but there's a kind of uh dismissal
and of them as human beings as if
capable of contributing of of doing
anything special and then here's you
have you know people who are sitting
there broke
um with big dreams they need the mentors
they need somebody to inspire them so
like
um I would criticize the flawed nature
of the message sure but also it's just
like you have to realize like there
needs to be
institutions uh or people or influencers
that help like Inspire right the problem
is though is the people who are pitching
unrealistic versions of that
are getting a lot of attention whereas
like there's so many great free courses
where you can learn everything and more
about
fulfillment by Amazon or about
copywriting or all these different
things that I think like so often the
air is just the oxygen is sucked up by
all the grifters who promise everything
it's back to what we said about
vaporware this is one of the reasons
that
um like educational products can so
often be co-opted by grifters is
vaporware is very hard to distinguish
because
prompt like the feedback loop on
education is not clear it's not obvious
immediately so I can sell you a book and
I can say this is going to change your
life if you apply it if you don't if
your life doesn't change I just say well
you didn't apply it right like it's it's
there's this weird relationship it's not
clear the value it's not so easy to like
quantify education so that gets co-opted
by people who make all the promises
they get a ton of attention a ton of
money and then those people are often
left left confused and like kind of
disillusioned maybe thinking well this
didn't work in one year so it's not
going to work at all
um and so I think yeah there there are
problems there there's certainly a need
for like male role models there's
certainly a need for somebody kind of to
speak to a younger generation I just
think that person shouldn't
shouldn't be maybe Andrew Tate like
personally yeah so you have to criticize
those particular individuals uh I also
and yeah I think that like the Bugatti
aspiration is so stupid like it's like
it's so well let me steal man so I'm a
person who doesn't care about money
don't like money
um the women maybe I appreciate the sort
of the the beauty of the other the other
sex but like sure
um yeah cars in particular is like
really is this really the manifestation
of all the highest accomplishments a
human being can have in life yes I can
criticize all that but the to Steel man
that case is um
a young person a dreamer has ambition
and I often find that education
throughout my whole life there's been
people who love me teachers who saw
ambition in me and tried to reason with
me that my ambition is not justified
looking at the data look kid you're not
that special yeah look at the data right
you're not and they they want to do they
want you to like
not dream essentially and then again I
look at the data which is
all the people I just talked to Hydra
Gracie this Hydra Gracie is just a
person widely acknowledges probably the
greatest of all time dominated everybody
but for the longest time he sucked
and he's so he was surrounded by people
that kind of you know don't don't
necessarily believe in him so he had to
believe in himself you have to it's nice
to have somebody I just as older I get
and I've seen it it's so powerful to
have somebody who comes to you an older
person
whether it's real or not that says you
got all these people I believe in you
sure
it yeah it does I mean
I think so
I think dreaming is actually really
important
I'm more protective over People Co-Op
those dreams for money yes yes and like
I do think it matters so much that we
encourage people to take risks it's one
of the great things about America is it
lionizes like sort of people have taken
risks and one
but
I think it's just a weird
vapid thing when like the reason you do
all of it is for this thing you can get
out at the end of the day when we all
know and you like you've just heard a
million interviews like nobody ever is
gets the Bugatti and goes this now
completely fulfills me everyone knows
the the Beauty and the like fulfillment
actually comes from becoming obsessed
about what you're doing for its own sake
sort of the journey the beauty of that
thing
um and I think money's just this thing
we have to deal with to be able to do
cool stuff like I acknowledge that you
know you need money to build the 10
million dollar Studio to like you got to
get the cameras you got to get the
lights and I'm very blessed to be able
to have gotten that but past a certain
point like I think that is really the
function of money is to just do cool
stuff but ultimately if you can't
fall in love with the process and like
the craft itself you will be left very
unhappy at the end of it
and so to start people off on that
Journey
by pointing to the shiny object and
going like that's what you should care
about seems to me so backwards we should
learn from the actual people who have
done it and said that shiny thing did
nothing for me
learn to love the journey and like
that's the thing we pitch people as
unsexy as that might be yeah absolutely
that's what I said and the same applies
to like the red pill community that
talks about dating and so on that
there's uh there is
uh it's not just about the number of hot
women
you go to bed with it's also about
intimacy and love and all those kinds of
things and so like it there there's
components to a fulfilling life
that uh is important to sort of educate
young people about totally but at the
same time feeding the dream and saying
take big risks sure and you the little
you that has no evidence of ever being
great can be great because there's
evidence time and time again of people
that come from very humble beginnings
and doing incredible things that change
the world yeah and there's just a
tremendous like funny thing where you
can't become great without having a
willful denial of the statistics like in
some ways you have to take the chance
even if that chance is so improbable and
it's always those people who did take
that chance to end up pointing so I
agree